i went back to my walk-through bedroom
and bobby kelly was living there was
three of us living in a walk-through
bedroom
bobby slept in the living room i slept
in the walk-through
and then our roommate who had the lease
he had the bedroom and uh we just played
roller hockey every [ __ ] day me and
bobby almost killed each other
and i lost my manager i lost my agent
i remember patrice you know he could be
so [ __ ] passive-aggressive yeah he
just goes like
damn billy you're back here it's just
like wow i mean
i know [ __ ] ain't happening for me but
like it's like at least
at least he goes he goes no wait he goes
at least
at least i feel like i'm moving forward
[Laughter]
he said that on the phone i remember it
really hurt my feelings
and i didn't because i didn't know how
to say it in the moment yeah
it's just like who said this my dick is
on the floor you got to jump up and down
on it what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] else do you need here like did
you befriend
like were you close with patrice at all
yeah yeah uh i used to sit in his car
at boston comedy club and so he went
while he was on stage yeah
because you couldn't park you know right
in front of boston yeah and so i would
go
it was in the car village when i was
yeah yeah it was kept over okay so you
were there when i was still in boston
yeah i barked there
i was that was my first barking thing in
the arctic too okay okay so
patrice was he ruthless to you
uh he was so the the i've talked about
it but like
he liked i learned quick to kind of just
whatever he
would think we i am i would just go with
it so like he would be like y'all not
believing dinosaurs
yeah i don't yeah like i would just say
whatever he wanted you know i've never
thought about that ever my life
like i've learned about dinosaurs like
but the fact that he thinks we didn't
i learned i was like well i'm yeah i was
like no we don't believe in dinosaurs i
would just go with it so i
i uh patrice was always very very cool i
met him
i mean until the last day i would every
time i talked about like hey nate i'm
friends with big j
i would say that and like at the end
he'd be like you're like yeah dude i
know who you are you know but you're
like i don't know
you know he was uh he was the best uh uh
ever saw but i was at their fame he was
at uh
burn his hbo one night stand taping you
were you were
i was there but then i remember them
warming up to it
like or running their set right yeah and
uh it was
running at the boston uh i remember one
night i recorded
i timed patrice's set because it was
like they had to do a half hour yeah
yeah and so when he got done i was like
hey you did like 36 minutes and i
remember him being like
all right and then walked away from me
and this is like because
he did it as a favor for him he didn't
ask he no he didn't ask
no no not at all dude like he this was
like young comic
you know trying to do it just i think
i'm supposed to do like i think
at that time well that you have it's
called a half hour so you have to do
30 exactly i have no concept of editing
or like you know maybe you gotta do 29
minutes maybe 38 minutes like whatever
the concept it doesn't really matter
and i just and i'm like so i tell him
like thinking i'm helping him he's
you know i think he was like all right
man like he it did not matter at all
like i called opie and anthony once i
was talking to them and anthony
anthony always has a gun on him he
carries a gun everywhere
like he has a concealed carry permit and
[ __ ] and i said to him i said
do you ever worry that maybe you're
putting out this energy and you're
manifesting something like some sort of
an attack on you
because you're constantly dwelling on it
you always have this gun
and patrice goes don't believe in magic
don't believe me conjuring up the world
hey man a positive energy
just starts laughing let me tell you
she's came out to la
right now la la commas are nothing like
us here
we learned a long time ago i live out
there you know but
i don't i'm not on the circuit out there
i can't you know i thank god that i'm
i'm able to tour and go out because i
can't
i can't deal like those guys it's the
most sensitive group of
they don't interact like this they don't
[ __ ] with each other what's the core
group out there
because we know the core group in new
york you don't even know it really isn't
one
you don't even i don't think it exists
there's no such thing there is no such
place as a coffee shop there's no
yeah [ __ ] and they're [ __ ] with
each other like every everybody's going
on stage but in their mind they're
it's their every time they sit on stage
is to make it like all right this is the
time
some producers gonna see me and i'm
gonna have my shelves absolutely
different yeah completely different so
patrice comes out right first of all let
me tell you what patrice does but she
stays in my apartment
right i'm in a two-bedroom apartment uh
at the time
i'm married uh so i'm like you know she
can stay with us it's no big deal
i put patrice in the guest room right so
one day i come home i'm gonna give you
guys a full fledge i don't give a [ __ ]
patrice [ __ ] him he could give me [ __ ]
later
so i come home right it's quiet i don't
i don't hear anything in the room
so i'm like patrice you here because you
know the rental car was in the garage
i don't know i guess not i go in the
back the computer's on
patrice is in front of the computer i
swear to god i cannot make this up
there's some baby oil
patrice is big so i can't see it from
the computer he's got the he's got the
headphones on
computer right so there's porn so
patrice is [ __ ] like his
his i guess he's got his dick out the
boxer hole
he didn't want to go with the full he
didn't want to go with the phone
so i see the arm i see the arm working
right so
oh please so my wife she's about to come
in and i bet no no no wait wait wait
wait
i'm like patrice you can't hear me cuz
got the [ __ ] headphones on
so i smacked i smacked the headphones
off his head i said
i say stupid what you beating your dick
in the [ __ ] office
he's like is your wife here so
hey man just cut this [ __ ] off
the most with the most humiliating move
i've never seen what she's doing
he wanted to finish he's like just get
out
i said you're not gonna [ __ ] stop me
you know his back was so big so i
couldn't i couldn't see anything grace
he's like just get out man
i'll be dead in a second literally this
is just worse i'm not gonna be done
i'm in your [ __ ] office so i leave
listen this is what makes for treatment
but she's coming out of liver masters he
said look look guys there's nothing to
say to really make that situation better
uh it is what it is uh it happened
uh so let's just let's just forget about
it
[Music]
when you first start start dating a
woman
um you know when she wants a
relationship when she comes over your
apartment what she starts to do is she
leaves [ __ ] there because it gives her
an excuse to come back
i mean it's [ __ ] nuts right like
they're thinking that far ahead oh
you're sitting there's like
look at those dead side what the [ __ ]
right that's all you're thinking and
they're sitting there
plotting you know what i mean it's like
you're some [ __ ] head coach that has
no game plan
and she's across the field like [ __ ]
bill walsh calling the first 25 plays of
the game
right oh i love a football life there's
a nice reference to use
um so you know what's [ __ ] hilarious
and speaking which patrice o'neil
benefit's coming up once again
i'll tell you a quick patrice story um
he was so [ __ ] brilliant that
i remember he was dating this woman and
you know
or whatever seeing her and she started
leaving [ __ ] around his house and i i
just had brought that up i go yeah you
know i dated this woman you know she
left this [ __ ] here and she left that
it's like what the [ __ ] you know i only
see her like you know once every two
weeks she just has [ __ ] there so for two
weeks i keep looking at
her [ __ ] brush or the shampoo she
left or whatever and it's just i keep
thinking about her and it's annoying me
and patrice just goes he goes
so throw it out i go what he goes throw
it out
i go i can't throw out a brush he goes i
would
i go get the [ __ ] out he goes yeah he
goes i did that he told me a story
but there was a woman he was messing
around with
and she left these toiletries and a
little bag of like you know makeup
and brush and all that and he he [ __ ]
threw it out
and then she came back like a week and a
half later
and she goes to go in the bathroom and
she's like uh
she's like hey what did you do with my
uh my stuff
he goes and he just plays dumb he goes
what stuff she goes i left shampoo here
a little makeup bag
he goes oh yeah i was showing yeah he
goes yeah i threw it out
and she was like literally beside
herself
but actually on some level respected him
for like [ __ ] realizing what she was
doing
and then also i think because that early
on
he clearly let her know in a very funny
[ __ ] way that he wasn't looking for a
relationship
and uh that she was able to relax and
kind of be thinking
oh we're just [ __ ] all right
i wanted a little more he doesn't at
least but he let her know
so [ __ ] early on that it didn't
really hurt
you know does that make sense i mean
maybe i'm speaking for her but
yeah i guess i am but whatever either
way it was [ __ ] funny